what's popping vampire Hunters it's me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show this video will be a breakdown of
the Marvel movie that started the
superhero movie Renaissance 1998's Blade
with a little bit of fun movie trivia on
the side so grab a blood bag and a straw
because we're going into this breakdown
raw originally released in August 1998
the first blade movie was written by
David S goyer and directed by Stephen
Norrington and of course starring Wesley
Snipes in his iconic role as the titular
Blade the Vampire Hunter however as
beloved as Wesley Snipes Blade would
become Snipes was not the only actor
considered for the role in fact at one
point new line Cinemas wanted to
completely race swap blade and make the
character a white vampire Hunter instead
but thankfully David goyer immediately
shot that terrible last idea down thank
you David you are invited to the cookout
but after that Mike DeLuca the head of
new line Cinemas had Denzel Washington
LL Cool J and Lawrence Fishburne in the
running as well before Wesley eventually
sniped the role at the end assistance of
David goyer and of course Lawrence
Fishburne would end up starring in his
own iconic role as Morpheus in The
Matrix a year after Blade's debut so
it's clear that 90s Hollywood had a lot
of faith in Lawrence Fishburne kicking
ass and looking good in sunglasses but
anyways when the movie starts with
Blade's mother Vanessa Brooks being
rushed into the emergency room her
wallet falls to the ground in all the
commotion giving us a clear view of her
driver's license which details that
Vanessa lives at 125 second Boulevard
apartment 201 in Braxton Florida we also
see that she was single 5'7 weighed 128
pounds and was born on February 16 1944
and after her wallet hits the ground her
library card as well as her MasterCard
credit card fall past the frame as well
then after a bloody baby Eric gets taken
away from his mother notice how Vanessa
keeps her arm reaching upwards as the
sound of her flatlining can be heard in
the background I think that this was the
movie's clever way of showing us a quick
Glimpse at Vanessa's transformation into
an undead vampire because typically when
somebody flat lines their arms go limp
typically but this introduction is
drastically different from Blade's
origin story in the comics as the
original Blade's Mother wasn't named
Vanessa at all but instead Tara Brooks
and though Tara does get bitten by a
vampire while she was pregnant Tara
unfortunately does not survive her bite
like Vanessa does later on in the movie
which is a bummer for Tara and while
Vanessa being bitten by a vampire while
she was pregnant is the reason why Eric
Brooks can walk around in the daytime as
a half vampire half human hybrid the
blade in the comics was not originally
born a day Walker at all but instead he
grew up as a normal human being who had
the luxury of vampire bites not
affecting him at all it wasn't until
Marvel Comics started changing the
character of Blade as a result of the
success of this movie that blade
actually became a day walking vampire
courtesy of one Dr Michael morbius
giving him a nice hickey but anyways
later on when Tracy Lord's Raquel the
vampire leads her unsuspecting dinner
date through that factory floor of human
meat on their way to the vampire Club
the poorly dressed soon-to-be
traumatized man notices a bunch of human
beings in blood bags being carted away
while this is meant to of course point
to one of the many sources of blood that
the vampires use for food these
human-sized blood bags were actually
supposed to play a bigger part in the
story originally according to production
designer Kirk petruccelli Deacon Frost
was initially supposed to reveal that he
had massive storages of these human
bodies in preparation for the day that
he would use the lamagra blood God to
turn every single human being on the
planet into a vampire because if
everybody on the world is a vampire then
that vampire planet is going to need a
food source or else everybody dies but
anyways after all those vampire freaks
get their disgusting bloodbath through
those sprinklers we finally get the
first appearance of the adult Blade with
a new and improved look and personality
that had not yet been seen in the comic
books because you see in the comics
blade wasn't always this badass in fact
after these movies were released Marvel
drastically altered the entire character
of blade in the comic book continuity to
closely match Wesley Snipes iteration as
the character at that time was very much
struggling in popularity amongst the
readers but anyways when that vampire
brings her date to that nightclub of
night stalkers we get our first look at
this universe's depiction of vampires
vampires that the blade producers made
sure were radically different from what
people traditionally knew about the
typically romantic personalities of
vampires starting the movie off with a
literal bloodbath inside of a nightclub
secretly inside of a human meat factory
David goyer does a rather fantastic job
at showing the audience how unconcerned
with the moralities of humanity that
these vampires are while still at the
same time showing us that these vampires
enjoy a lot of the same recreational
activities that modern day Humanity
enjoyed at the time having these
vampires look and dress like regular
young people rather than your
traditional count Draculas or The Count
from Sesame Street honestly helped this
new universe feel a lot more scarier
because these vampires can literally
walks amongst Society at night and blend
in perfectly but anyways when blade
finally arrives to the nightclub seen
wearing sunglasses at night to watch the
vampires breathe their last story lines
we can finally see how much this movie
was inspired by Chinese Cinema in fact
it was Wesley Snipes himself who came
into the project specifically with the
Deep desire to make a kick-ass superhero
action film that felt as badass as the
martial arts films that they were making
in Hong Kong but anyways after blade
kills 22 vampires in the club I like how
they ended that sequence with the blade
essentially crucifying Quinn and
although Christian iconography like
crosses don't kill vampires in this
universe I like how they still threw a
nod to that type of traditional holy
vampire execution Style by pinning the
vampire Quinn to the wall like Jesus and
then burning him alive but unfortunately
also very much like Jesus Quinn would
return from the grave also if you're
wondering blade will apparently kill a
total of 88 vampires over the course of
this movie so for the love of God give
that man a good Yelp review that's just
some good service right there and also
fun fact when the police arrived to find
Quinn Burning Alive we were originally
supposed to get a stand Lee Cameo here
as one of the cops but his Cameo was
unfortunately cut I also really enjoyed
how they made blade mysteriously
disappear before the police arrived on
the scene in a very batman-esque way
this feels extremely intentional to me
as screenwriter David goyer has said
that they all looked very closely at the
Batman movies for guidance and
inspiration while crafting this movie
specifically the Batman film by Tim
Burton and its realistically dark
atmosphere goyer's deep love for the
Batman world would of course eventually
land him as the story writer for the
Nolan Batman Trilogy as well as the
screenwriter and executive producer for
Batman v Superman one of those things is
a lot better than the other but uh I
won't say
with both blade and Batman being
nighttime Avengers taking creative
inspiration from Michael Keaton's Batman
movie was definitely a wise decision
especially knowing that they purposely
made the effort to avoid the cheesy
mistakes of the Batman sequels that
followed sequels that significantly
toned down the adult themes and violence
in order to appease parents and tap into
a younger audience and during the
hospital scene when a charred and
resurrected Quinn Attacks An
unsuspecting Karen actor Donald Logue
actually dislodged his jaw after his
face accidentally forcefully landed on
the ground and after screaming out in
pain the production had to ironically
Rush log from their fake hospital to an
actual real Hospital while he was still
in the makeup of a dead burn victim
which freaked out pretty much everybody
at the hospital and later as Whistler
checks out a bitten Karen Jensen's
wounds we can see that Whistler is still
wearing his wedding ring giving the
audience a hint that Whistler used to
have some type of close family in the
past before Whistler reveals later on in
the film that his wife and two daughters
were brutally slain by vampires and
actually the character of Abraham
Whistler is an original creation for the
blade movie made to be a loose
adaptation of comic book Blade's actual
original Mentor Jamal afari in the
comics Jamal afari is an old black
vampire Hunter who ends up being the one
to take Eric in and teaching him
everything he knows about making
vampires run for their lives or their
afterlives or whatever types of lives
vampires actually have not sure why they
felt the need to do that and I very much
hope that Marvel Studios includes the
Jamal lafari character in their
adaptation but anyways later when
Whistler tells blade to steady Karen on
the table we can see a great example of
just how strong the film's main hero is
when he uses just one hand to keep a
convulsing Karen from shaking her ass
off the table and right after this when
we meet the Council of vampires sitting
together at a glass table notice how the
tops of all of their chairs are all
curved I believe this design Choice was
a direct nod to the design of
traditional famous vampires like Count
Dracula who it's often times wear capes
with curved collars so all the vampire
players on the console all sort of look
like they're wearing curved vampire Cape
collars themselves as they sit back like
this was a super dope choice in my
opinion because all of these council
members essentially represent the
classic vampires of old who likely
probably did have a wardrobe similar to
your count Draculas where your count
choculas at one point and their
extremely long-lived lives as pure blood
vampires and also learning that Stephen
dorf's Deacon Frost is not one of these
pure blood vampires but instead merely a
former human who was converted into a
vampire very much reflects his
character's personality and motivations
in my opinion because human beings as a
species have historically had strong
proclivities towards conquering other
people that they see as weak and
consuming things in excess it seems to
me that the filmmakers are heavily
implying that the malicious and Evil
part of Deacon Frost's personality is
heavily rooted in his human DNA because
the pure blood vampires in the council
were naturally born that way they
appeared to completely lack Deacon
Frost's very human-like thirst for
living beyond one's means and insatiably
reaching out for more like these old
vampires are perfectly content with just
being left alone and hiding in the
shadows with Humanity ruling the world
and Deacon Frost is not about that but
anyways a little later when dragonetti
confronts Deacon Frost while he's
translating the sacred vampire attacks
on a big ass CRT computer screen the
translated text on the right of the
screen seemingly tells the story of the
origins of vampires in this universe
specifically how the blood God lamagra
used to rule a completely dark Earth as
the God of all vampires until an ancient
force that the vampires of old referred
to as the Unholy one defied La magra's
Rule and built a prison for the blood
God before supposedly creating the day
and night cycle thus forcing all the
vampires to hide in the shadows while
Humanity evolved and prospered but the
prophecy does leave the vampires with a
sense of hope when it promises that
Humanity will end up destroying their
own selves by destroying their habitat
which is true and that the coming Return
of the blood God will convert all of
humanity into vampires and allow the
vampire species to reclaim the planet
that was stolen from them I wrote the
entire prophecy out just for you and
will now place it on the screen here
just in case some of you are thinking
about changing religions anytime soon
blood God yum yum blood God all hail the
blood God what a mighty blood God we
serve but anyways after blade drops
Karen back into the daylight she heads
back into her apartment I really like
how the set designers decorated her
sun-lit space with a little smiling Sun
as well as a painting of a sunflower as
all of that serves to give the audience
a false sense of solar security a sense
of security that gets Shattered by
Officer Krieger right before blade
shatters Karen's tame table with
Krieger's body and later when Krieger
runs away from blade we can see blade
whips out a weird-looking Square gun
that machine pistol is actually two
real-life guns combined into one with
the trigger half of the gun being a Mach
11 and the front half of the gun being
the casing of a Mach 10 and later as
blade has a car chase with officer
Krieger we can see director Stephen
Norrington feasting on a woman on a
nearby Street Corner which I thought was
a fun little Easter right but anyways as
blade and Karen prepare to enter the
building that the cop just went into we
can see a boxing poster for Dunner
versus Fresno this poster was actually
featured in episode 12 of season 1 of
Star Trek the Next Generation so
technically blade takes place in the
Star Trek universe okay not really but
it's more fun to just think it is I
could see Jean-Luc Picard as a vampire
Captain's Log I'm thirsty for blood then
as blade and Karen make their way to the
back of a club full of sunglass wearing
Japanese vampires they run into the
extremely large vampire Pearl hidden
within the club's refrigerator which is
hilarious considering that Pearl clearly
has some type of dieting issue I mean if
you count eating human babies and
infants a dieting issue anyway which is
exactly how Pearl became that big
according to director Stephen Norrington
so you know don't feel too bad that
Karen cooked that nut job slob of a blob
also fun fact about how Pearl was made
there was actually five people inside of
Pearl's body made up of seven thousand
dollars worth of silicone with the actor
Eric Edwards as the head of pearl one
dude for the left arm one dude for the
right arm and two people puppeting
Pearl's legs and after Pearl is cooked
blade and Karen then enter the Erebus
archives where the pages of the vampire
Bible known as the book of Erebus are
stored an aptly named vampire Bible too
as Erebus was the god of primordial
Darkness according to Greek mythology
also I love how they made the design of
Deacon Frost's sexy time bed look like a
high-tech metal casket as vampires are
of course famously known for sleeping in
coffins the movie uses this metal bed
the best during the Vanessa Brooks
vampire reveal scene as the metal coffin
opening symbolic points to Vanessa
rising from the grave that her son
thought she was in this entire time but
anyways as Deacon Frost makes his way
through his house party while ignoring
Krieger you can see a vampire girl
watching the Mortal Kombat movie on a TV
screen which was another adaptation from
New Line Cinemas that came out a year
prior in 1997. then after Whistler helps
blade and Karen escape the Erebus
archives the three start walking along
the side of a train tunnel but what is
crazy about this moment is that Whistler
inexplicably disappears from this scene
completely after his bomb explosion
causes him to lose his footing only to
reappear without explanation in the
following scene where did Whistler even
go like how the hell does a normal
senior citizen of a human being survive
falling off the side of a tunnel onto
the path of a moving train and survive
something tells me that whistler's
original fate was probably to die during
this moment but they probably changed it
to make Whistler into a vampire for a
potential blade sequel but that's just a
hypothesis for now but anyways I found
the converse conversation that happens
when Deacon Frost holds a little girl
Hostage to be quite interesting because
it shows how similar blade and Deacon
really are as Half-Blood vampires in
their own unique ways Deacon tries to
recruit blade to his cause not just to
manipulate blade into giving up some of
his special blood but also because he
can relate to Blade and how it feels to
not 100 belong to any one group they're
both two powerful people that feel like
outcasts to both humanity and the
vampires so the movie having Deacon try
to extend an invitation to Blade to join
his group despite everything that blade
has done to them seems to be reflective
of Deacon Frost's overall hatred of
being made to feel inferior by both the
Vampire High Council and Humanity at
large so he tried to reach out to his
fellow Underdog but ends up calling
blade and Uncle Tom when blade refuses
to join him but anyways later on after
Deacon Frost finds whistler's hideout in
mortarly wounds Whistler badly Whistler
calls blade a son of a which is
super great foreshadowing in my opinion
because Whistler was 100 on the money as
Blade's mother would prove to be a
massive vampire only a few short
minutes later I've known some
blood-sucking in my day that's
why I no longer use OK Cupid and as sad
as this scene is for the movie
apparently Wesley Snipes could not stop
cracking up he just found the image of
him lightly dabbing the wounds of a man
bleeding all over the floor to be too
damn funny to say in character and
honestly I don't blame him I'd probably
do the exact same thing it's kind of
ridiculate like why is he dabbing
Whistler when it's not really doing
anything seems kind of kind of stupid
but anyways in the following scene we
can see blade cut the roots of the
flower that he's been caring for this
flower is actually called the dracana
leukospermum and it's a hybrid of two
different species of plants much like
blade is a hybrid himself blade
symbolically cuts the roots of this
plant to also symbolically show his
disdain for his own vampire Roots after
his quest to avenge his mother got his
father figure killed blade Echoes this
mentality later on in the movie when he
says I must release you to his mother
before killing her love that line so
much because it both implies that blade
is both releasing his mother from her
vampire corruption while also releasing
her as the main motivation for his
entire life and then we get a dope ass
Lobby fight scene that very much gives
off The Vibes of the lobby fight scene
from The Matrix but again seeing as this
movie predates The Matrix by a whole
year that simply could not be possible
it's just kind of weird that Hollywood
produced two badass action sequences of
a man in sunglasses clearing out a Lobby
full of goons in such quick succession
like that it was like back to back
basically and at the end of the movie we
of course get that final sword fight
between blade and a powered up Deacon
Frost with the power of the blood God a
fight that was originally not in an
earlier draft of the film a deleted
scene from the movie was supposed to
have Deacon Frost completely transform
into this massive crappy CGI blood
monster that was supposed to chase blade
around the room but test audiences hated
how it came out so much that they had to
change the ending to make it more
relatable two human looking people
fighting each other is much more
interesting than a man fighting a giant
red blob I mean what is this Thor the
Dark World to get that out of here
but speaking of deleted scenes when
blade and Karen say their goodbyes in
the sunlight an alternate scene was
supposed to tease Dr Michael morbius At
Your Service for Blade 2 with morbius
standing on top of a nearby building
however of course when they realize that
the rights to Dr morbentine belong to
Sony's Spider-Man deal they had to scrap
the entire scene and their plans for
morbius much like they had to scrap
their plans for Whistler to appear in
the movie's final moments when blade
arrives in Russia to fight vampires
because apparently right before the
credits one of the earlier plans was to
have Whistler himself be the vampire of
Blade faces off against at the doors of
the Russian club which honestly would
have been super dope but I think blade
has been traumatized enough for one
movie especially after his vampire mom
tried to seduce him or whatever what the
hell was that scene about like Jesus
Christ that may be so uncomfortable the
lesson of the day if your mom starts to
flirt with you you should probably call
Blade because she's probably a vampire
or from Alabama either one of those call
Blade he'll take care of it
just kidding people from Alabama are
totally fine and don't sleep with their
mom I think I don't know but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
breakdown of Blade 1998. you can follow
me at mastertainment on Twitter
Instagram or wherever I am on the
internet but most importantly follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube because
we got some interesting stuff for you
guys all the time and you guys do not
want to miss out but again thank you
guys so much for watching you guys were
amazing and I love you guys and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye